agressive de temps la russie croit-elle
que c'est le temps qu'il doit faire le
premier pas pour améliorer les relations
oui on part de cette prémisse parce que
nous n'avons jamais commencé la
dégradation de nos relations ni avec le
temps et avec l'union européenne et avec
toute autre partie occidentale ou de
tout autre pays du monde tout le monde
le connaît très bien
lorsque saakashvili a donné ses ordres
criminels de bombarder la ville de ce
qu'ils valent et bombardé les positions
des
troupes des mentions de la paix en
automne 2008 c'était la russie qui a
demandé la convocation de conseil de
sécurité et le secrétaire d'état à
l'époque condoleezza rice a réfusé bien
que lors de la création de ce conseil
russie otan hans était prévu dès le
début que le conseil doit être tout
temps et surtout doit être convoqué en
situation de crise ce n'est qu'un seul
exemple en route rigueur qui a
commencé la dégradation de la situation
jusqu'à l'état actuel entre nous les
temps mais cela vaut faire le président
est de gauche a annoncé que ce n'était
pas possible de résoudre le sort de tous
les pays en ajoutant qu'il existe une
feuille de route en fuite de route pour
se mettre d'accord ce principe alors
l'éloquence du président aulas quand
reconnu par tout le monde il leur procès
parole avec la liberté pour toutes
sortes de sujets je suis d'accord avec
lui que les cinq membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu n'a pas le
droit de dicter les soeurs de l'humanité
c'est vrai mais le conseil de sécurité
et les membres permanents ne prétendent
pas d'avoir ce droit tout ce que nous
prétendons c'est d'avoir nos pouvoir
fixer dans la charte de l'onu qui
reflète la volonté collective de tous
les membres de la communauté
internationale et ce sont les cinq
membres du conseil de sécurité qui ont
cette responsabilité pour interdire en
conflit global et on a su le faire
pendant les décennies et j'espère qu'on
sera le faire pour l'avenir évidemment
nous avons la nécessité d'adapter le nué
et le conseil de sécurité pour répondre
à au contexte actuel parce que dans le
monde on n'a plus une cinquantaine de
pays que c'était à l'époque de la
création ni même le 70 pays on rencontre
maintenant 5 92 parmi les membres de
l'onu seulement et de la part de
nouveaux pays et des pays émergents elle
est tout à fait raisonnable de vouloir
leur rôle renforcé au sens du conseil de
sécurité parmi les 15 membres du conseil
de sécurité l'occident représenté par
six pays au monde mais lorsque le
conseil de sécurité 1re soit les pays de
l'asie et du japon ça veut dire c'est la
septième fois pour la politique de
l'occident alors l'occident ne doit pas
voir renforcer son rôle ni augmenter le
nombre de ses participants au contraire
les pays émergents de l'afrique de
l'amérique latine et doivent ils prendre
sa place mais cela vaut faire sur le
temps le temps a déclaré regretter le
fait que la russie et suspend un
suspense son fonctionnement de ces
missions à moscow pourquoi l'alliance
aggrave encore une fois les relations le
conseil russie otan va-t-il continuer à
travailler et deuxième question c'est
lens qui s'est dit prêt à avoir une
réunion avec poutine sow tous formats
possibles mais dans le même temps le
porte parole du président russe dit que
cette réunion est peu probable la partie
ukrainienne peut-elle sollicité une
telle réunion et est il vrai que madame
nous l'inde comme on est annoncée à qui
elle a demandé de rejoindre le format
normal vous en avez fait quatre
questions pas deux
alors quand tu as le temps j'ai déjà dit
comment c'était commencer comment les
représentants de l'alliance ont enterré
les règles qui ont été mises fondements
de ce conseil et notamment la nécessité
d'un gendre et les consultations dans
les situations de crise et on avait vu
on les a vus continuer cette politique
alors ce que les américains ont souhaité
unis en coup d'état en ukraine en
2014 et l'union européenne
à riom fait en vue des activités de
l'opposition bien que la vie de ce coup
d'état les pays occidentaux dont la
france et l'allemagne en garantie
les
ont donné des garanties de la part de
l'alliance de l'oignon et européennes
est juste le leur demande l'opposition a
fait piétiner ses
obligations il faut pas aller loin pour
en voir d'autres exemples on peut dire
la même chose sur les messages lancés à
partir des capitales occidentales pour
notre part entreprise qui a n'était
qu'une réponse contre les trois passes
successives fait peur
les représentants de l'otan lorsqu'on a
réduits plusieurs foi nos effectifs dans
les représentations pour entrer pour
pénétrer dans l'état major de l'otan nos
représentants sont obligés d'envoyer une
demande au préalable pour l'accès au
bâtiment il doit vous
suivre seulement le couloir que leur
sont autorisés et bref
lorsqu'il s'agit des échanges
d'informations c'est qu'un quasi
inexistant depuis longtemps et le plus
important ce qu on a coupé d'une façon
officielle tous les contacts avec les
militaires alors
de quel up pertes de possibilité de
dialoguer peut-il s'agir il ya deux ans
nous avons à proposer et s'était fait
part à valérie guerassimova le chef de
l'état major général de la fédération de
russie faire éloigner les exercices
militaires
de
des frontières russes
de négocier l'existence est minimale
n'est pas à faire violer par les navires
et les aéronefs mais on n'a pas reçu de
réponse lorsque les ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'allemagne au
déclare que par ce pas la russie fait
preuve eux qu elle n est pas prête pour
les négociations moi je viens de
rappeler
nos pas entrepris pour lancer des
négociations qui ont été ignorées par le
temps alors hop célébration donné par
leurs représentants occidentaux on y
trouve la compréhension de la faiblesse
de leur position et leur volonté de
faire porter le chapeau par quelqu'un
d'autre à ce qui est né reflètent que le
manque de la culture diplomatique en ce
concerne les propos du président c'est
lens qui on a beaucoup parlé à propos de
ces rencontres
leurs dirigeants de son cabinet en a
parlé son conseiller je me souviens plus
lequel est monsieur skis en personne à
la aussi parler il n'y a pas longtemps
quelqu'un de son au cabinet aurait dit
que poutine aurait été prêt mais son
entourage on ne lui conseille pas de
rencontrer les skis en tête à tête parce
que les résultats de cet entretien on
pourrait être imprévisible alors ce flux
de conscience et d'inconscience je ne
commenterai même pas toutes les
déclarations qu'on entend au sujet des
contacts probables possibles à un haut
niveau ou un autre et
à propos de ce qui se passa dans basse
et autour d'eux le crès nation et c'est
de donner des commentaires
on ne pourra pas le faire
parce que ses fantasmes son quotidien
est assez fréquent en ce qui concerne
les électeurs et un hollande alors à
l'époque
[Musique]
john kerry et occuper cette poste de
secrétaire d'état il est venu plusieurs
fois à moscou elle a été contrait pas
boutinet le président avait dit que les
américains influencé le cren à part le
représentant spécial et porsche n qu
écouter ses conseillers et poutine a
proposé de faire appliquer l'allemagne
et la france pour améliorer l'état de
choses et ensuite on a demandé aux
allemands et aux
français qui ont été contre les
modifications de tout format aps pour
respecter le format de minsk et les
accords de minsk est pas obligatoire
d'être de faire partie d un
du format nude ferment de minsk pour
aider à
améliorer la situation parce que les
américains ont une influence dominante
pour aller skier pour son cabinet on a
repris le dialogue noland rencontre et
kozak qui est responsable pour le
vecteur rien et les pays de la coi ils
ont accepté de poursuivre les contacts
et
franchement si les américains le veulent
s'ils le sont vraiment prêts à soutenir
le respect des accords de minsk la
sphère sera réglé assez rapidement est
ce que je peux
vous dire bonjour donc
je suis encouragée à poser cette
question par ce sentiment de solidarité
parce que gilad imagine qu le
journaliste de kébé est toujours en
prison alors que
komsomolskaïa pravda est interdite en
biélorussie en tant que agents étrangers
comment pourriez-vous le commenter j'ai
déjà donné de commentaires on pose cette
question de voir nos parts nos collègues
ukrainiens on continue à nous en occuper
rt france bonjour messieurs lavrov
première question la russie est elle
prête à devenir le premier pays à
reconnaître les talibans en tant qu'
autorité officielle de l'afghanistan et
quelles sont les conditions pour cela
deuxième question les états unis ne
participeront pas à la réunion dans le
format de moscou sur l'afghanistan cela
va-t-il influencer l'importance de cette
réunion mais qu'est ce que c'est si
difficile s que ça va enfin c'est
l'importance de cette réunion
la russie a déjà déclaré sa position
pour les
sujets des talibans on est au contact
comme la majorité des pays influents
sans la région et nos eaux
pour seront à surveiller le respect des
déclarations faites par les talibans à
leur arrivée à la pouvoir y compris
l'europe à leur
obligation d'assurer à la représentation
de toute la population au sein du
gouvernement
la reconnaissance officielle n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour ce qui était a été
déclarée d'une façon officielle et votre
la deuxième partie de votre question
les états unis la participation dans la
réunion le nouveau représentant des
états unis chargé de l'aghanistan
messieurs
en a parlé à laver des formats de moscou
et la zik ils voulaient absolument
entrer en contact et rêver venir dans la
fédération de russie et les bienvenus
nous serons heureux de le voir